gibt es leben im weltall also außer uns
wenn ja wo befindet sich darüber gibt es
jetzt neue erkenntnisse die fakten dazu
jetzt bei klick zum salzen fiktion
ja solange wir menschen schon zum
sternenhimmel gucken so lange fragen wir
uns wohl auch ob wir allein im universum
sind bisher konnten wir die frage nicht
beantworten aber die suche nach
außerirdischem leben wird vom vorstand
vorangetriebene aber wo soll man da
draußen suchen forscher vom harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics kurz
cfk halten es für möglich dass es leben
in sogenannten kugelsternhaufen geben
könnte kugelsternhaufen dass eine große
ansammlung von vielen sternen sie kommen
recht häufig in der milchstraße vor und
sie liegen an deren rand den
kugelsternhaufen m 13
den kann man übrigens schon mit einem
einfachen fernglas am nachthimmel
entdecken seine leuchtkraft ist rund
300.000 mal so hoch wie die der sonne
das besondere an diesen stern ansammlung
ist die alter sie gelten als sehr alte
sterne population 2 nennt man das vor 10
milliarden jahren sind sie meistens
entstanden und daher hat man sie bisher
als ort für erdähnliche planeten
ausgeschlossen
bisher wurde angenommen dass für
planeten der entsprechenden größe
bestimmte materialien benötigt würden
die schwerer sind als helium oder
kohlenstoff zum beispiel diese schweren
elemente haben sich jedoch erst später
gebildet sie sind zum beispiel durch
supernova entstanden die wissenschaftler
haben allerdings den gegenbeweis
gefunden es gibt planeten die um sterne
kreisen die nur sehr geringe teile der
elemente enthalten das kann also auch
auf kugelsternhaufen zu treffen aller
gray vom tata institute in mumbai sagt
es ist daher voreilig zu sagen dass es
in kugelsternhaufen keine planeten gibt
die wissenschaftler halten es auch für
möglich dass es auf den erdähnlichen
planeten in die google sternhaufen
außerirdisches leben geben könnte
sie nehmen sogar an dass dieses leben
höher entwickelt sein könnte auch hier
liegt der grund im alter der sternhaufen
potenzielles leben hätte hier einfach
sehr viel mehr zeit gehabt sich zu
entwickeln
die möglichen planeten befinden sich
sehr nahe an ihrem stern bei denen
handelt es sich nämlich um rote zwerge
umgangssprachlich wird so die kleinste
art von stern genannt ihre leuchtkraft
ist verglichen
zum beispiel mit der sonne sehr gering
auch die kernfusion in ihrem inneren
läuft langsamer oder viel schwächer ab
weshalb sie aber länger existieren
können was sie kleiner und schwächer als
die sonne sind befindet sich die
habitablen zone viel näher an dem stern
selbst diese zone beschreibt den abstand
eines planeten zu seinem gestört bei dem
die zustände durch dessen einfluss die
entstehung von leben zu lassen ein
lebens freundlicher und erdähnliche
planet ist also näher dran an seinem
stern als unsere erde an der sonne
diese lage schutz die kugelsternhaufen
planeten auch mehr zitat wenn sich dort
planeten bilden dann können sie doch für
sehr lange zeit erhalten bleiben erklärt
rose die stefano vom cfc bei großen
stern kann der einfluss der gravitation
einen planeten zum beispiel aus seiner
umlaufbahn bewegen die erforschung der
kugelsternhaufen gestaltet sich
allerdings aufgrund ihrer großen
entfernung als schwierig von der erde
aus ist ein roter zwerg zum beispiel
einfach gar nicht erkennbar die hohe
dichte an stern macht es für die
wissenschaftler auch schwierig einzelne
planeten zu erkennen bisher wurde auch
nur ein einziger planet entdeckt aber
immerhin ein anfang
dennoch sind die chancen dass
außerirdisches leben entdeckt werden
könnte gestiegen wissenschaftler können
dank der neuen erkenntnisse ihr
suchgebiet ausweiten
es sind rund 150 kugelsternhaufen
bekannt und die wurden bisher auf der
suche nach außerirdischen lebensform
vernachlässigt die forscher gehen jetzt
sogar so weit zu sagen zitat ein
kugelsternhaufen könnte sogar der erste
ort in unserer galaxie sein an dem wir
intelligentes leben entdecken sagt er
die stefano wir haben ja schon öfter
videos über aliens gemacht glaubt ihr
dass es möglich sein wird außerirdisches
leben vielleicht schon bald zu entdecken
was sollten wir tun wenn wir tatsächlich
kulturschaffende wesen entdecken würden
schreibt sie in die kommentare
abonniert den kanal kostet ja nichts was
einen daumen nach oben da wenn euch das
video gefallen hat und schaut euch das
nächste video an
bis dann auch moment in der video
beschreibung und hier oben unterm dach
da gibt es einen link zu unserer alien
playlist ich sag nur die aliens sind